[Música]
un grito a la lengua
[Aplausos]
y estaba nervioso
[Música]
y saben que cuando empieza con estas
realidades si no tiene estas ideas uno
empieza a meterse en su propio rollo
mucha gente habla que en verdad
hoy vamos a tomar para poder abordar
nuestro destino porque nuestro cerebro
de los caballeros esto fue un pacto
porque un pantano imagínense horita
todos un pantano es algo de repente
lúgubre algo húmedo a lo extenso tiene
diferentes charcos y estos mismos
charcos nosotros los utilizamos para
poder mandó a cenar diferente
información información algunos
jugadores de fútbol los nombres de
actrices nombres de actrices que no
comparten con su mamá y su papá
y cada vez
movimientos de fifa de call of duty de
forma que muy fuerte y por acá
esta junta
y también como ustedes pueden ver en ese
pantano tenemos todo tipo de información
no tres canciones artistas de la vende
cuando animarles
todas esas cosas están almacenadas allí
en nuestra mente y es dentro de esos
fantasmas dentro de eso se forman
nuestra personalidad forma quienes son
nosotros hoy por hoy
lastimosamente cada quien tiene un parte
muy diferente y son ustedes los que van
a decidir qué hacer en ese pantano
si podemos tener la siguiente porque
aparentemente
y experiencia personal cuando lo he
adolescente yo tuve muchos problemas
para poder encontrar mi vocación quién
soy yo yo creo que hay personas que hoy
por hoy tienen 40 años y no saben que
quieren ser en la vida de que quieren
ejercer y hacer su futuro hay personas
que ahorita a los 40 yo a los 32 años
del 41 conferencista me dieron ganas de
ser panelista pero solo con ver que se
levante una parte de acs
porque como yo tengo a dios
y es por eso que quise inicio yo quise
trabajar como electricista pero viendo
las imágenes de subir ustedes de un
poste así como está el caballo ahí
presente y no pude por más que lo
intente integrarme en fin parte de los
equipos porque habían varios grupos de
trabajo donde nosotros hacíamos
prácticas hay investigaciones encender
el tren todo lo mismo que todos los
elementos que forman a una a un
profesional yo fui parte de ellos como
grupo nunca puede ser parte del equipo y
por eso me tocó hacer varios giros en la
vida así que espero que han tomado
pastillas los baremos cuando vamos a
tener bastantes tiros pero comencé así
como electricista pero luego
de ser electricista pase a tener una
fase donde yo le viste a dios ya va a
tener haremos ejercer la verdad y
misionero anduve por varias partes de
honduras sirviendo a mis hermanos y en
mis compatriotas entre ellos ya son un
como torno a ver
ama la barra de google adwords riotinto
también como estuve por la zona centro
con nuestros libros médicas y estuve
también por la zona de prensa para dar
una batería y ahí pude entender algo de
mí mismo a pesar de todos mis miedos
porque durante mucho tiempo yo he vivido
con inseguridad exterior mente por mi
peso
gracias
pero por todas esas cosas yo sentía
ciertas inseguridades sin embargo cuando
yo trabajé como misionero tuve la
oportunidad de ayudar a las personas y
hacerles de repente portales entre vito
de arena por eso cuando llevaba
[Música]
y entonces estuve como misionero yo
logré entender qué
frente a las personas que está frente a
la gente de alguna universidad hasta que
le gusta a la gente
sin embargo toda esa niña como misionero
todo tiene su fin
y si fue a ganar
en un call center
porque entra en averiguar dónde está el
ford center quiero que sepan que yo como
muchas personas ha ocurrido buscar el
trabajo y la ayuda con un presente y ahí
pueden también desarrollarme como
profesional algo que siempre me encanta
hacer tipos de voces como lo he
mencionado por ahí
fue vocalista de una banda de metal
y ahora vienen de corbatín y todos pero
volviendo a nuestro tema mientras yo
estudio por ser yo puedo aprender a
poder ayudar a las personas ya sea por
asistencia telefónica y como muchas
personas de repente acá presentes han
tenido esa experiencia trabajar en un
call center no es cosa fácil y realmente
entiende que no siempre el cliente tiene
la razón
y algo que me llama la atención que para
mí es un gran privilegio creo que soy el
primero por ser conferencista álex y
premio por eso
pero para mí es un trabajo justo puede
descargar porque por medio de esta
industria depot center yo puedo entender
muchas cosas de la vida número uno todos
tenemos problemas número 2 lidiar con
nuestro problema de manera muy diferente
sin embargo siempre necesitamos ayuda y
ahí lo entendí que la psicología era
reunir
porque yo amo puede ser de influencia
positiva de más personas
yo amo poder hacerlo el día mejor a
otras personas y de repente poner la
felicidad con la seguridad de la otra
persona antes que la nuestra
estuve acá aprendí a ser diferente
[Música]
en el final 9
del lugar a diferentes estudiar como
también poder ser un número lo cual es
muy gracioso mientras estudios chinos se
iban porque vieron a un gordo armado
al rato engañado y automáticamente creen
que soy mínimo
e
[Aplausos]
los sueños de esas personas
el viernes
volviendo a nuestro tema
me abrió las puertas a poder entender
que todos sus mimos diferentes problemas
y mientras yo dibujaba porque no quería
trabajar con un call center o como
muchos dicen sean gente pasar a
supervisor basadas en gerente y poder
escuchar los demás personas como ellos y
en sus propias catársis externalizar sus
problemas y pude ver mientras yo
dibujaba porque yo dibujaba bastante y
yo miraba entre más dibujaba y más ponía
aclaraciones de marisela
i
en cheste
y logré entender que la depresión y la
creatividad
en realidad están manejadas por veces
entre más tristes o más deprimidos que
estamos más creativos no volvemos y esto
es algo muy peligroso los entendidos
porque a veces nosotros esta misma parte
de la depresión es algo que muchas veces
los agentes heridos un psicólogos
psicólogos y al investigador de hungría
construyó donde aceptó 28 personas que
tenían tendencias depresivas le dijo
materiales para poderse desarrollar y
las personas más creativas
también tornaron con un resultado muy
interesante tiene un gen es un adn que
lo vuelve de percibo ahora
entonces yo soy creativo es porque estoy
deprimido y no ha sido bueno
tampoco la niña ni al día
entonces qué pasa nosotros como seres
humanos tenemos esa belleza de poder
sobresalir ante nuestra adversidad de
poder crear
y sobresalir muchas personas prefieren
mantenerse en el pantano que les gusta
de inicio de sus pensamientos y por esa
zona de confort no quieren salir porque
en esta vez de la mentalidad tenemos dos
grupos de euros
y dónde no
porque por si no lo sabían la flor de
loto y la degradación de un río la flor
de loto sale de un pantano y a pesar del
fondo del mango el barco de lodo del
agua sucia de pasarte todo es la flor de
loto en el eje y se ve tan bonita
existen modos que no dependen de usted
de dónde quiere estar porque si estamos
teniendo nos mantenemos en nuestra misma
mentalidad de que evadió hermano para
que me voy a poner en eso porque no voy
a hacer porque nosotros comenzamos a
deprimirse
ahora la depresión que en la depresión y
la depresión
es un trastorno mental severo que se
caracteriza por un estado permanente
constante de tristeza y la medida de
poder ser felices y no me refiero
a
porque me pedirá porque es alguien que
se fue de móvil
pero es aquello que día tras día las
semanas seguimos triste
y eso es la depresión es amor patológico
ahora esto estuviera tiene diferentes
síntomas pueda que sea esta una pérdida
de apetito la felicidad la grande
sanidad a bañarse del cuerpo
muchos factores pueden que se
manifiesten todos a la vez sólo uno
ahora me pregunta para ustedes
y lo es
escuchar las canciones de shakira
antología donde decía que se aprende sin
bañarse los dominicos
es acaso escuchar canciones melancólicas
y escribir en un cuadernito pero nadie
podía caminar
muchas personas manifiestan su depresión
haciendo ejercicio constantemente u
otras personas
y en el reino temas porque lo que yo
quería lo que yo quería llenar como
vacío que tenía dentro de verdad esas
personas te vistes y podemos ver de
repente en diferentes medios como
nosotros vemos actores cantantes de por
qué
a pesar de hacer felices a muchas
personas a pesar de dejar un legado de
felicidad se toma esa decisión
lastimosamente con la depresión es lo
que tenemos que saber es ese pantano que
tenemos que sacar y para poder verlo
como un loco
cuando yo saqué con todo lo que
importaba le he contado acerca de ser
electricista bien contados misioneros
que se contaba acerca de ser call center
o también he estado a otra faceta que
intente ser político y que mi pueblo
la intendencia de ser diferente en cosas
que están haciendo
pero que está haciendo
porque muchas personas tienen aquellos
enormes talentos
esa grande estabilidad en que usted
quisiera tener para hacer una receta
única para poder timo maas algo bonito
para poder crear de la nada
muchas personas quisieran este derecho y
todo lo hacen tienen ese miedo vivir en
ese pantano de sí mismo que no le
permite salir adelante docente los
deberes de los ojos y ver que ellos
pueden hacer grandes cosas porque qué
pasa de repente equivalen a mil
inadaptados sociales no hay mano será
sino hermano no perderá será un grupo
donde todos son iguales no lo es
lo que pasa es que de repente surge es
mucho más lento porque no importa el
arte de proveer no importa que usted
esté ganando de garantizarle
con solamente garantizada
el arte que usted está generando lo
tiene audiencia no importe delante que
sea siempre va a haber alguien que le va
a buscar lo que usted hace su novia
personas si se puede de hecho buenos
seguía adelante yo he conocido historia
que solita con nosotros conferencista
que mi hermana
música escucha
y es lo que hacía
con personas que les gusta ustedes van a
encontrar ese dibujo yo porque logré
entender por lo que la vida ha ganado
logré
salir de ese portal y volverme un loco y
así que la juventud es este doctor me de
honduras es un grupo de comediantes
tengo alguna persona quien dice
invariable que él es un comediante que
trabaja conmigo nos están queriendo ese
apellido honduras están dos candidaturas
es entrever que dios me ha dado aparta
de mí está presión a partir de mis
problemas advierte toda adversidad este
es el producto todavía está en
crecimiento de repente en la primera que
está dando escuchando lo leemos lo
buscan pero si ustedes se dan cuenta los
mismos trabajos de los propios autores
van a comer bien en nada sí pero que
seguimos adelante porque yo soy un loco
quiénes son
los locos somos todas aquellas personas
todas aquellas personas
no más
no más de pensamientos negativos no más
de que yo no puedo más de que yo soy
gordo que yo soy pobre
no más excusas
[Aplausos]
porque los lotos vemos adelante salimos
salimos del fango salimos de
el pantano vamos a salir adelante lo
único que quiero decir a ustedes los
esperamos el grupo local os esperan
muchas gracias confidencias
[Aplausos]